So did you figure out what caused the error? Hopefully
you discovered that it was this one. The first query orders
by name. And then you added the inequality filter from
max attendees. So the first sort order is name, but it
should really be max attendees, because that's where we have
the inequality filter. Composite index not existing might be a problem
that you run into, but it isn't the problem this time.
Unless you deploy straight to app spot, in which case you've
got a couple of different errors going on. And again,
this is a problem you might run into. If you
try to filter, say, on max attendees greater than 100,
and seats available less than ten. Because then you'd be
using inequality filters on two different properties in a single
query. But in this case, this particular error should not
be the problem. We're only using an inequality filter on
a single property. So, here's the arrow in the API's
explorer, and you see it tells us exactly what the
problem is. First sort property must be the same as
property to which the inequality filter is applied. In your
query, the first sort property is main. But the inequality filter
is on max attendees. So when you get these kinds
of errors or any errors, don't be frightened by them, just
go ahead and read them. There's valuable information in the
errors that will pinpoint the problems and help you fix them.